and one of them is the former shadow
foreign affairs minister stephen dirty
and as i'm saying very good afternoon to
you mr. Doughty I'm good ask me the your
resignation gave mr. Gannon a lot of a
man ammunition to throw at your leader
was your timing deliberate no not at all
and I just come to a decision this
morning and based on the the sacking of
my colleague Pat McFadden for very
reasonable and write comments about
terrorism and national security and that
given that I held those views as well
that it was only honorable for me to
step away from the front bench as well
but I mean let's so look at the overview
mr. Corbin is the leader as we're off
told by by a thumping majority isn't it
within his rights within your party to
to fashion the front bench in his own
image to have people who won't be
disloyal well leaders always reshuffle
and but I think the question of
disloyalty I think is one that's
extremely misleading Pat McFadden has
served loyally under a number of Labor
Government's and in opposition has been
one of our most effective ministers and
shadow ministers his man held in high
regard by colleagues in all parts of the
party and singling him out for his very
reasonable views on such a serious
matters national security I think is
extremely regrettable well I mean it
wasn't just that was it i mean you say
he was loyal well i did an interview
with him last year when he talked about
how labour was becoming all yoked labour
wouldn't become a protest group under
jeremy corbyn well i think a lot of
things we said during the leadership
election about the fuse then an senses
let me just afterwards mr. gorban was
well installed as leader bat'leth
vladden as shadow europe minister came
on my program on a sunday and gave me a
lengthy interview about labour turning
into a protest group well I think what I
think one of the things that impressed
me about Jeremy and why I agreed to
serve on the front bench in the first
place was his willingness for have
honest and frank discussions and that
straight talking on his politics which I
I took her face value and certainly you
know I have great agreement with Jeremy
on a whole series of issues tax credits
climate change tackling the Tory trade
union bill which I was pleased to lead
our opposition to in the comments and
but also we've got to have the ability
to have a frank and free discussion
about about matters and not to play
internal party politics are indeed
cross-party
six with matters like national security
and defense and I think it's only right
when I have the same views as Pat on
those issues and would have said exactly
what he said in the comments that day
about terrorism and tackling the
narratives about the West but it's the
honorable thing for me to do to step
away too so you've got to turn that
around and the narratives there in
blaming the west and western foreign
policy and motivating terrorists you got
to turn that r and n so you and Pat
McFadden believe that the leadership of
your party actually subscribe to that
worldview well no i don't and i actually
criticized david cameron directly in the
Commons chamber in the Syria debate
about his a disgraceful use of the term
terrorist sympathizers and at the same
time I've criticized Jeremy directly
about his associations with the stop the
war coalition which i think is said
absolutely unacceptable things following
the Paris attacks and I think it's
regrettable and that him and his office
have continued to associate with that
organization that's right well then it
does subscribe to that worldview doesn t
mean he hasn't disassociated himself
with it and was on their website wasn't
it stop the war coalition that some
terrorist attacks sir as a result or
related to Western foreign policy
actions well no actually his own which
Jeremy did disassociate himself from
those comments and indeed he did a very
dignified non erable thing following the
Paris attacks in laying wreaths at the
the embassy and but I don't think it's
appropriate that the party continues to
have associations with that organization
which let's remember Caroline Lucas
Peter Tatchell and others have have
separated themselves from because of
their views and whatever its role it
might have played in opposing the Iraq
war in 2003 unfortunately has taken on a
whole series of individuals and
positions but I simply can't support and
as I said fundamentally this comes down
to very very serious matters of national
security and defense and others and and
given that I hold the same views as
parts on on what he said about
narratives around terrorism and he's
been sacked for that reason I think it's
only the honorable thing to do for me to
step away as well fatma Fadden also said
he hoped that the reshuffle wouldn't be
Petty and divisive before it happened
you think it's turned out that way I
think for aspects of it have done it yes
and I think it's extremely regrettable
that mysteries are being briefed out
from the leaders office just this
morning
and I think that's really regrettable
particularly when it's about
long-serving and hard-working members of
both late previous Labor Government's
and also in opposition and individuals
like myself who who took the decisions
serve despite you know having all these
differences with Jeremy and others about
some key matters and thought it was in
the best interest of the party and and
if an effective opposition to do that
but in the end it comes down to a matter
of conscience and I certainly couldn't
after what happened in the last 24 hours
continuing my role given that Pat being
singled out in that way yeah you talk
there about individuals like myself so
there are a lot of others well there are
a lot of individuals who clearly have
concerns about aspects of labor policy
and you know and also have differences
and actually we've always been a broad
church and a lot of that debate is
conducted in a very comradely and
friendly matter and as it should be on
matters of such seriousness but when
mysteries are being put out about
individuals and when we're playing
internal party politics essentially with
matters of national security and then I
don't think that's the way that we
should be headed and I've always
believed that these issues should go
well beyond party politics and certainly
beyond internal party politics and the
politics of individual score settling
well I mean what so what's your estimate
about the number of your colleagues who
think along your lines that think that
mr. Corbin and his acolytes have made
this Petty and divisive well I think
there are a number of colleagues who
have serious concerns about what's
happened in the last 24 hours I mean I'm
not going to give a number i mean it's
for individuals in themselves to speak
up about their concerns and to take
their own decisions i can only make
decisions for myself and i felt felt it
was the honorable thing to do to step
away and given that i agreed with
everything that pat said in a statement
that he has been sacked for how do you
think mr. ben is going to conduct
himself staying in posters shadow
foreign secretary but we all know the
dogs in the street know he's been
muzzled well as far as I understand
that's absolute nonsense and I'm sure
Hillary would say say the same and I'm
sure he's going to speak out on a series
of issues in exactly the way he would
have before Hillary is an
extraordinarily principled and and
long-standing
m figure in the labour party and I'm
sure he's going to continue to be that
way just as he was in the debate over
Syria if he'd be moved horse act what
would have happened well I think a
significant number of individuals would
have left their front bench roles and as
it is a number are choosing to leave
their roles anyway and but you know the
threats and the Makana of imaginations
that have been going on for weeks now
when really we should have been focusing
on and the tory government failures over
flooding and the chaos over the EU
referendum and you know on a very day
that we saw great divisions in the Tory
party we had a reshuffle lasting you
know for hours and hours and hours and
then some quite divisive moves at the
end of it I think mr. Corbin comes out
of all this do you see him as a prime
minister well Jeremy koopman is an
extremely principled and and unpleasant
individual I'm and I've had personally
no problems with Jeremy honor on a
personal level it's always been
extremely courteous to me we have very
clear disagreements on a whole series of
issues and and I think Jeremy is
principled and and mature enough to be
able to cope with that kind of
disagreement I think what's regrettable
is is some of the operation around him
and that is continuing to undermine
colleagues that is continuing to breathe
out complete untruths to the media and
whilst at the same time told telling us
that they're talking about straighten
honest talking politics and you know
that's a complete and you know
contradiction in terms and it's got to
stop and that's all that happens I think
it's gonna be very difficult to find the
sort of unity that all of us want to see
in the Labour Party was about newseum
ultimately as prime minister we're
talking about the internal workings of
the Labour Party now the public are
watching and eventually mr. Corbin has
to reach out to them to try to become
Prime Minister well Jeremy was elected
with her with a huge mandate and he has
absolutely the right to put that forward
before the country and we've got key
elections this year obviously in May and
you know we were all out speaking to
voters every week and you know a number
of them are very pleased with the whole
series of things that jeremy has been
doing and particularly the work we've
done in tackling and the plans to cut
tax credits and cut the police issues
that would have affected my constituency
massively jeremy has my wholehearted
support on those and he was absolutely
right to take the positions that he did
and but there are also areas where
clearly the public have concerns and
a number of those are around national
security issues and and and you know I
want to hear a much clearer affirmation
from the leadership of the Labour Party
around these issues and as I said stop
associating with organizations that
appear and to equivocate over those such
as stop the war coalition I don't put
words in your mouth but it sounds to me
as if you're saying in an elegant way as
it stands with that particular policy
you're unelectable well I speak with my
own words I don't need them put in my
mouth timid but no I think there are a
whole series of issues that we had to
set out we're very early in in in a
parliament and we're well away from a
general election and we clearly have a
number of key tests this year but
fundamentally those will be fought on on
local issues in Wales we've got an
excellent first minister in Karen Jones
and an excellent Welsh Labour government
has continued to deliver on its promises
and is protected the Welsh people from
serious harm when it comes to health and
education and some of the reforms that
we've seen in England and I'm going to
be really proud to be standing on a
platform of fighting for a Labour
victory in Wales in May just hearing
your colleague Kevin Jones has also
resigned followed your your lead I mean
is this coordinated if you have you
talked to mr. Jones I will not speak to
a number of my colleagues all the time
and you know Kevin's a close colleague
and individuals had to take their own
decisions about these these matters and
I certainly did this morning and
Michalek joined reynolds has obviously
decided to go for his own reasons as
well and in the end this comes down to a
matter of of conscience and personal
views and and I certainly felt that as a
colleague of mine Padma fat and in the
same team foreign affairs team where i'd
worked with very closely somebody who I
respect immensely given that I have the
same views as him that he'd been sacked
for I felt it was only the honorable and
right thing for me personally to step
away what other individuals decide to do
is up to them but presumably you
wouldn't be surprised if a few more
follow your lead well there are a number
of individuals with concerns but whether
or not that leads to their resignations
as I said is a matter for them and I can
only speak for myself and I felt it
wasn't honorable for me to stay and
given the concerns that I had and I you
know I'd hope to be able to stay but
unfortunately the way that things were
handled over the last 24 hours meant
that I couldn't just one a year I just
returned to the issue of mr. Corbin you
didn't quite answer that it's he
excellent you said you're Welsh leader
is excellent
is mr. Corben well I think there are
concerns about the way that and the
Jeremy's leadership operation works the
way his office conduct itself and I
think those are our concerns they're
going to have to be addressed and you
know in order to bring out I think and
the the best aspects of of what jeremy
has to offer and I thought it was
extremely disappointing for example that
on a day when we'd had such significant
victories about tax credits and about
police cuts and that the media coverage
for the day was dominated by John
McDonald's waving of my little red book
and those are sorts of errors and and
and perceptual issues that I think quite
frankly needs to be addressed because
they are overshadowing and very very
real wins that we've had on a series of
issues and and you know I want us to be
focusing on those you know as I said we
should have been focusing on on the new
divisions in the Conservative Party and
the the unity and the Labour Party on
that issue and instead of course it's
all been thrown off but I mean here you
go on her out about the team around mr.
Corbin and mr. McDonald II go on about
their the foot shooting the missed
opportunities tell the government to
account having surely you must then
believe the party your party would be
better off if you had a different team
at the top well there are individuals i
think need to reflect on the way that
they're conducting themselves in in mr.
Corbin's office and elsewhere and
ultimately you know it's a decision for
him how he decides to and to handle the
makeup of his top team you know they're
individuals in every labor Lisa's office
so I think you had different points of
cause problems we all we all so it's a
prisoner I mean you do you think mr.
Gordo a prisoner there then of those
around him I mean the other view is is
that he's appointed them his special
advisers and others and he wants them
there well I think Jeremy and I don't
know the internal workings of fees is it
his office on a daily basis but I would
like to see him and challenging some of
the the behavior that's been going on
certainly in the last twenty-four
forty-eight hours and some of the
mystery that being put out this morning
because I don't think it fits with
Jeremy personally it's not the kind of
Jeremy that I know and I've not heard
him utter these types of things about
people before obviously you can have you
know cross disagreements with
individuals over issues as does any
leader but I've not heard him engaged in
these type of things and I think or I am
you know I would hope that his team
reflected that that kind of
behavior that he engages in but if it
continues this way I mean you wouldn't
be sad to see him saying I've had enough
and let someone else have a go well
there's no there's no prospect of any
kind of leadership election or anything
like that at the morning can walk Jeremy
Joe well you know Jeremy was elected
with it with a significant mandate it's
one of the reasons that I agreed to
serve despite my disagreements with him
on a number of issues and unfortunately
I felt that I had to step away in last
24 hours because of the handling of this
specific issue but you know I'm going to
continue to support him in in those key
areas and you know that I've mentioned
you know and our fights against the way
the Conservatives are running the
economy the way they're dealing with the
welfare system and you know tackling
climate change globally and tackling
cuts in the police service you know
these are crucial issues and you know
fighting the trade union bill which is
going to do so much damage to workers up
and down this country those are issues
on which there's complete unity between
myself and Jeremy and many across the
Labour Party and I hope it's those
issues we can get back to focusing on in
the days ahead ok we'll end it there
thank you very much indeed mr. Doughty
Stephen Doughty there the former shadow
foreign affairs minister as you heard